today friends are remembering the
boulder city pilot who was killed in a
crash near the nevada arizona border
over the weekend 73 year old richard
mayahan died saturday when his small
plane went down to mohave county joe
moller joins us live from the boulder
city airport to share more about the
pilot joe
friends say the plane that richard was
in was a kit aircraft that he stored
here at the boulder city airport friends
tell me he was a very experienced pilot
and many are now curious about what
happened
73-year-old richard moynihan is being
remembered by many in boulder city after
a crash in northern arizona this is a
photo of a hangar at the small airport
with a message saying rest in peace
friend curtis campy says moynihan was an
experienced pilot who served in the
military he says he saw him at the
airport days before the crash and is
shocked by what happened it's a very
nice airplane i finished it about a year
and a half ago
i think there are only about 150 hours
on it
he's a pretty mellow flyer not like some
of us who like doing a little more
aerobatics and formation flying rich
really wasn't into that so
we're all really curious what happened
you know campy says moynihan's plane was
called an r-7 kit aircraft he expects he
was going for a short flight or to
somewhere for a bite to eat he says he
will be missed by many in boulder city
back out here live the faa and the ntsb
were notified about this crash and they
are investigating what exactly caused it
to go down reporting live in boulder
city joe moller live local now